let's turn back if we can to the upside
world of the Democratic Socialist Party
this very strange relationship that they
have with democracy now it is a word
that almost everyone on the left they
love to repeat over and over and over
again they claim to cherish and rever
democracy both here at home and around
the world but well in reality uh
Democrats seem to love democracy in name
only as Democratic Professor Jonathan
Turley points out they're now moving to
bar Donald Trump and other Republican
candidates from ballots all over the
country in some cases they're using
activist judges who are unelected in
Maine you have a far-left Biden loving
Secretary of State unilaterally removing
Donald Trump from the Republican primary
ballot well so much for letting the
voters decide now the longtime Democrats
said it was quote her duty to block
Republicans from voting for Trump oh one
person decides and then in the great
Commonwealth of Pennsylvania Democrat
now there they're attempting to remove
Congressman Scott Perry from the ballot
and according to Jonathan Turley the guy
that filed the challenge is a former
Congressional candidate who made
headlines burning Maga flags with swas
stickers outside of cour houses great
resume in every case a common theme the
word Insurrection it's a phrase used by
democrats Trump haters over and over and
over and over again talking about
January 6th they always forget the words
peacefully patriotically March to the
capital so your voices will be heard
that always gets ignored now they're
using Insurrection as an excuse to ban
Donald Trump other Republicans from all
future elections now none of these
candidates including former president
Donald Trump were ever convicted of
insurrection as a matter of fact they
were never charged and up to now have
never been charged with Insurrection in
other words Democrats are trying to
completely upend what is a real Democrat
itic process one they claim to Revere
solely on the basis of their own
political smear now this is what you
would expect from the what Communist
party and the old Soviet Union not
really from people that claim to Revere
democracy now of course many Democrats
don't actually care about democracy they
just want power and perpetuity one party
no checks no balances and no descent
they believe deeply in their hearts that
we the American people we simply cannot
be trusted
and they we should not have any say in
deciding the vote take a look at the
2024 Democratic primary look at North
Carolina with Biden's popularity at an
all-time low State officials there
accepted a request from the Democratic
party to actually remove every candidate
from the primary ballot except for Joe
Biden what a great system I applaud
North Carolina it's just a little too
risky to actually have voters have
another option does that seem like real
democracy to you but this is just the
beginning ultimately Democrats would
like to expand the Supreme Court we know
about that they want to pack it with
Democratic activists that would
legislate From the Bench they would love
to Grant statehood to Washington DC and
Puerto Rico they believe to secure four
more democratic US senators and of
course they would absolutely love to
Grant amnesty to 8 and A5 million new
reliable voters who they aided and
embedded in law breaking and now they
would Grant the great gift of
citizenship but of course I'm sure they
wouldn't expect votes and return for
that great gift would they not the
people that dared to insist you know you
come into the country legally you're not
going to vote for those people the
people that said follow the law respect
our borders respect our sovereignty
respect our laws this is all about power
and perpetuity not democracy so when you
have a Democrat on fake news CNN or
msdnc proclaiming their love for
democracy just know there are nothing
more than wolves and sheep's clothing
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else